thank you
[Music]
Taliban the Taliban I don't like the
Taliban is worried about Andrew Tate oh
as they as they ask for his freedom
isn't that sweet what is it because that
because Andrew Tate was protecting him
on Piers Morgan I don't know you tell me
okay so the backstory to this which is
really [ __ ] funny is Andrew Tate's
been going on Pierce uh Morgan a lot and
then there was a segment where Pierce
was like basically questioning his take
on the Taliban he was like why do you
support them why did whatever and he was
like wait I never said I supported them
and then he goes on Pierce goes on to
another segment talking about yeah I
don't know why he didn't condemn the
Taliban and I don't know why he supports
them he goes well no
this is he was misquoted right and I'm
not here to protect Andrew Tate or
anything like that but me but protect
him I just think that there's so much
[ __ ] that happens with Pierce where
he takes something that you say and
clickbaits don't hate that [ __ ] yeah so
bad he's supposed what agitate said was
specifically I don't support the Taliban
but who am I to judge a culture that I
have no idea about and called him
barbaric when we do the same thing in
Western countries so he's like if I
condemn them I have to condemn my own
countries that makes sense so I was like
big brain that makes sense and he goes
and then at the end of all that pierce
was like so you still won't condemn
you're such a stupid right honey I
smooth brain that's the exact same
formula that he ran on Ben Shapiro when
he was talking about exactly it's
exactly the same but that's but that's
how they get you in mainstream media
right is you just narratives repeating
it over and over and then people go I
can't believe he didn't condemn the
Taliban you know he loves these Barbers
Trump won't condemn Russia no matter
what the [ __ ] no wonder Andrew Tay likes
the Taliban he's a oven is just like
them and it's like what the [ __ ] like
[ __ ] right
shut up dude remember Bill O'Reilly
Obama doesn't care about the Border
[Laughter]
he was deporting everybody so this is
why this is even more funnier it's
because now the Taliban is supporting
Andrew Tate saying
let them out he's our friend that's kind
of tight and now it just confirms it
even more when he isn't a Taliban
supporter pretty [ __ ] honestly I
don't know what who's in charge of
Taliban right now but their trolling is
like next [ __ ] love I think it's CAA
is it it's Matt magazine
survivors.com
so the there's going to be a Twitter
space
um soon with the Afghan Taliban to
discuss the detainment the outrageous
detainment of Andrew Tate let them out
they're worried about them they want to
know if he's free yet they do it he was
arrested and where like Romania Romania
yeah and they say that westerners need
Andrew Tate more than ever because we
are oppressed by feminists oh my God a
lot of women agreed with that yeah good
really yeah do you guys women agreed
with that wait wait the best thing women
are oppressed by feminists too one of
the my favorite things that Andrew Tate
said is that he gets he has his chick
make him two cups two coffees why yeah
one for one hand and like me like this
look
I have two cups of coffee in the morning
because each one of the ring and jumps
the coffee no he he um he has her make
two cups of coffee for him so that he
can drink one and then the other one he
just leaves there because he's like you
do that for me because if anybody was
ever to come in here I would have to
throw my [ __ ] life on the line to
defend you so you just made me two cups
of coffee [ __ ] don't ask questions I
was like that is so yeah like yeah let's
go man you wanna know my favorite one is
my favorite engine he really said that
yeah he did say that you guys two copies
one one for the one I'm gonna drink and
then one for just in case that's it and
that's the only reason and he goes I
want to touch it but my favorite Andrew
Tate line ever he goes uh why would you
get tap water why would you go to a
restaurant why would you get still water
it's for poor people he's like don't
drink that you you get seltzer water
every time you always get soda water or
something like that just because it's
it's bubbly and
poor people don't drink that
and that's why I'm like this guy kind of
Next Level
yeah
still water at Joel Rubicon where we
were thirsty as [ __ ] and we went and we
pounded like a hundred dollars worth of
water and we saw the bill I was like I
wouldn't even order water I would wait
till end of the meal and got it out of
Fountain if I knew it was going to cost
this much so you want to be a poor
person I do you got to think outside the
box Joe didn't know Joe was poor you
gotta have a reptile in mind now what
are more uh Andrew Tate lines that you
like uh mostly the seltzer water yeah
the two cups of coffee things struck me
I just like love the idea that that um
there'd be like you know this lady who
just died recently and she's like uh she
died at 115 years old they asked her
what was the secret she said oh just
hard work and and loving sweets and no
one gives a [ __ ] yeah and she made it to
115 with a perfectly happy life and yet
we want to listen to people in their 20s
and 30s and 40s and constantly changing
their minds about what's good yeah and
we're all just like wait now that's the
thing okay let's all do that but Andrew
take's mostly right though who got to
the Finish Line yeah there we give them
one line in the paper well like thank
you goodbye yeah but have you ever
talked to your very relevant have you
talked to your grandma before yeah how
many followers does she have she was
dead when I was alive how many followers
did this 115 year old person have
probably not that many so then why would
you even listen to yeah what how many
views did she get yeah she has no views
dude no it's such a 41 firewood listener
it's such a funny what a seesaw but
that's how it is though like the reason
why Andrew Tate is like super popular
the reason why [ __ ] liver King is
super popular is like we all like this
character yeah we yeah we love hearing
like the extreme sides of everything
like that's just where we are now I
think yeah
don't we love a good bad guy like like
when you're watching WWE like watching
like the under the wrestler dude he's
Rick Flair yeah exactly which is with
some better points Ric Flair was the
best at it maybe ever like no matter who
yeah whoever you are like you wanna none
of you can be first but a whole bunch of
you can be next yeah give me a break
just sick Ted DiBiase everyone here that
guy man yeah dude everyone [ __ ] hated
him yeah yeah it is he was talking about
for everybody it's cool to see the the
people that you admired in wrestling now
be real life people oh yeah it's kind of
true that part is pretty crazy yeah but
that's that's the social media like the
anti-hero you know what I mean yeah like
nobody wants to outright be like I'm
like a bad guy yeah but the anti-heroes
the ones that like are are [ __ ]
constantly flirting with the line those
ones are so funny they know how to like
play the audience and people don't want
a boring answer you know all of our
problems the answers are usually like
very very boring and like what do you
mean save five bucks a day
what do you mean like what do you mean
walk 10 minutes a day no away Jose I'm
gonna eat both testicles
the thing about educated too is like he
makes some really good points at times
but then he also says some wild [ __ ]
that you can't discern whether it's like
yeah you can't hit it or if it's real so
it's like it's so dumb that I can't even
believe that he said it and then I
actually watched the clip and he's
saying with a straight face and I'm like
is he putting no zip on it at all like I
think this cat actually what do you
think it is do you think how much of it
is like I think he knows what he's doing
it's exhausting to listen it's hilarious
yeah it's some of it's really funny but
it's something that's exhausting listen
to like because I know that there's some
dudes out there like you know it's kind
of like when I was doing trolling satire
[ __ ] where it's like oh like sex and
public print gone sexual there's some
kids who thought that shit's real and
that scares the [ __ ] out of me oh so for
you you're more afraid of the audience
not him yeah they don't get it or they
don't get it and they think that some of
that's tight but he didn't do fake
pranks yeah what the [ __ ] dude you tell
me that [ __ ] was fake joking with me
honest but no but that's the thing it's
like it scares me to think that there's
any kid out there who doesn't have a
father figure who can be influenced by
that stupid [ __ ] exactly actually like
tell a chick to make him two cups of
coffee or whatever because like he's
like that means I get respect and it's
like what the thing he's gonna be alone
forever and that's on him I know but so
many people follow liver King and Andrew
Ted at the same time yeah well liver
King kind of demoed his whole thing like
but people are still gonna fall I think
it's exploding bigger than ever yeah he
reached a wider audience because of this
yeah
but you know if you the anti-hero what
do you say to the kids that like can't
figure that out there's nothing you can
do because you can't Prime everybody to
receive information yeah because they
don't figure it out you know what I mean
is that on appearance all directions
like even with satire you can't trust
that everyone's gonna understand the
nature of your joke there's going to be
some of the comments going how could you
say that yeah yeah don't you like that
things like that exist because it's fun
it's it's like
we can't control it all we can't help it
all but I love the fact that it exists
because we can laugh yeah and it's
interesting like people I like when
people get really fired up over like an
entertain or like a liver King because
then you see like like Greta thundberg
yeah like the whole Greta Thunder thing
like everyone just she owned them great
anti-hero she [ __ ] pan
why he went after her she did on him no
he was like he was I don't know why he
just took shots he most liked uh tweets
Twitter posts in history really yeah
yeah like
[ __ ] he he went at her and then she
said something like uh I have a small
dick at whatever uh smalldickenergy.com
email me and they had like over three
million likes to became the most liked
being on Twitter I would think that's
also kind of messed up yeah because now
the small dick guys like what I gotta
take another Hill hit dude take another
[ __ ] Ally like they didn't do
anything
I'm a tiny dick guy what I gotta take
another L yeah dude that's how I felt
that's still [ __ ] funny to me I mean
that [ __ ] was funny that wasn't very
Greta thundberg no she's getting older
maybe it's the new ground did it say
account managed by mom
really no she's like she's like 19 now
she's 19 right yeah she's allowed to
[ __ ] talk about small she likes him
he's a [ __ ] she basically put that out
there we're set to be rated in 10
minutes by even she's 19. no I mean but
you know like the whole conspiracy
that's going on she's 19. you're a
conspiracy she's old enough for more
than just kisses they only went after
Andrew Tate because of that is that is
the conspiracy Alexa what's the statue
of limitations
asking the FBI goes oh don't call back
well you want to know stupid
[Music]
[Music]
foreign